[Music]
I'm Katie I made it I said it I ate it
Here I am from New Orleans Louisiana and
I'm about to artis aka the legendary
Katie Reed iconic that was known to be
the first transgender blaze homosexual
rapper Nas artist that is Miss Katie red
a legendary bounce artist who's been
doing it for over 20 years but before we
get to her story what exactly is bounce
people may call it working the correct
name party bouncing shakiest music bass
music you'll shake aJE's music the
origin of Bounce music can be traced
back to the mid 80s to a DJ duo from
Queens known as the show boys they took
the theme from dragnet and sampled it
into this eventually it made a switch to
New Orleans where the beat got sped up
looped and by the early 90s bounce was a
mainstay in New Orleans music soon
enough bounce went from a hyperlocal New
Orleans sound to influencing some of
mainstream's biggest artists like Dre
and Beyonce
I don't know what he just bought that
sound but whatever that sound be and
have you moving to your feet baby my
first concert I was scared I was I was
scared I was so nervous
[Music]
[Applause]
then I got up there and I was like you
know how y'all doing so like and it was
screaming out loud like we love you we
love that music I'm like oh like that
was like what a big relief it takes a
certain amount of brashness and bravado
to make it as a bounce artists let alone
as an openly gay or transgender woman
but Katy is not one to shy away from
anything me opening doors for a lot of
the bounce tortoises and I like gay
tortoises I think about that a lot
the mound scene is more acceptable at
first it wasn't I was bored and brave
but at the same I was scared but I still
had to do me a lot of gay guys - welcome
to me and say ok the YouTube is not so
my my was again because I was like a
little listen to music but how many
people be who they are and who they
really want to be do you only get one
life and nobody can run your life with
you
[Music]
[Music]
you